hello everyone and happy new year
everyone I didn't show any videos
yesterday or the day before that well
today before that I was taking the day
off but I was really looking for the
best possible game to show you you know
just to start the year in in a proper
way you know we can just start a year
with a game where you know nothing
happens and then one player wins the
game because he's up upon that that's no
way to start a year so this is a game
from a tournament the the lorca open
tournament that took place in Spain from
26 to 30th of December which coincided
with the world rabbiting blitz
championship and we kind of didn't well
we didn't cover it kind of went under
under our radar but not really
daba da da hosted it on Twitter and he
tagged me in his post so he made sure I
don't miss it so thank you for that Dov
it and a lot of you have afterwards also
sent to this suggestion so it's it's a
game between two grandmasters Spanish
Grandmaster Mark Narciso Dublin and
Ukrainian Grandmaster Vitaly ben
bernanke and it's just a brutal game i
mean you will enjoy it I will tell you
that and it kind of reminds you of a
Gorgon it's a versus style in a way that
one player was able to take advantages
of of the position since it doesn't
appear like the opponent has any
weaknesses but he actually does but it
also kind of reminds you of a rota level
versus Rubinstein Rubinstein is immortal
game in a way that well the bishop pair
was utilized to you know how would I
even say it the bishop pair was just a
fully operational but yeah now that
being said let's just check it out since
that's what what we're here for
and I do have a small announcement but
I'm gonna save that for the end of the
video so that being said white opens
with d4 now we have Knight to f6 c4 g6
and now f3 avoiding the groom field so
asking like what do you want to do here
you could still go for d5 but after
captures and captures you are not
attacking the knight on c3 so after e4
you're just gonna have to go back with
the knight and the groom field players
that don't really enjoy this setup yeah
so butter up the g7 and now efore we
have an
ice King's Indian wit wit f3 we have
castles by black and now Knight to c3 if
you're a king Cindy and player and you
you're just starting out you maybe enjoy
the Kings India instead of never be
afraid of the e5 move e5 doesn't really
do all that much for white you can go
back to e8 and this is a good square for
the knight since you can easily
undermine White's Center later on
there's even a game we covered well it
was some time ago by Bobby Fischer his
opponent lady five and lied later after
the game Bobby Fischer just said in an
interview that his thoughts on the e5
move were that it's weak he just said
weak so that's that's what you should
think about a five but okay Knight to c3
we have c6 preparing to further expanded
the center would be six maybe d5 later
on Bishop to e3 and d6 now with a knight
- g - e - all this has all been played
before we have a six and now since white
doesn't want to meet b5 he pushes c5 and
now if black decides to trade for
example captures captures and trade
Queens which is usually something black
wouldn't mind doing here
white occupies the D file and also at
the C pawn completely stifles blacks
development on the Queen side you can't
really do much here so just Knight bt7
Vernadsky continues development we have
seek after Sun b6 e captors and d6 and
now well some moves have been played in
this position like Knight a for Queen to
d2 preparing to trade off the dark
square Bishop Knight the c1 was played
with ideas of Rima new ring denied that
other squares Knights the g3 is a new
move in the position and it is as of
move tended we have a completely new
game so b5 now there is no c5 to prevent
such an expansion and since f3 was
played the center is nicely protected
white doesn't have to worry about b4 so
just Bishop to e2 white continues
development and c5 now which is always a
useful move you're preparing Bishop to
b7 to open up this diagonal and well
you're just attacking white strong
Center we have castles and here comes C
capture sandy for this seems a bit a bit
of an unprincipled move since you're
breaking the tension in the center
without seemingly gaining anything but
after the exchange captures captures you
do get the the Seif of an e5 squares for
your night so that that could be a
compensation however you are left with
the week isolated d6 pawn but you know
you're playing black you have to concede
somewhere so Bishop the b7 or black
continues development we have looked at
a1 and now rook the c8 continuing
development white does the same Bishop
to f1 now the rook nicely controls the
e-file rook to e8 and now rope the c1 or
all four rooks are now fully developed
and here Knight to e5 your IE v square
is now free to be used as an outpost for
the night and if black wants to kick it
away he will either have to change the
structure of the game by by playing
something like f4 which you don't really
do as this really strengthens blacks
light square bishop or you give up the
dark square bishop which you simply
don't do here so Queen to b3 connecting
groups developing the Queen also a a
four might be an idea to undermine those
pawns as the b7 point the b7 Bishop is
undefended for the moment but black just
continues playing on the Kings side with
h5 now h4 is coming you're going to kick
away this night and instead of
continuing with something like rook cb1
which you know the game just continues
white plate Knight to h1 he said okay I
don't want to meet h4 coming with an
attack on tonight so I'm going to
Riemann over the night either way maybe
maybe with ideas of Knight f2 maybe to
d3 to trade off the strong knight in the
center
however Knights the h1 actually loses
the game for white so feel free to pause
the video and try to find why this is
the game of the year while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting two very important things
first that the King doesn't really have
all that many squares the bishop and
Knight really make it awkward for the
King you know to enjoy his chambers and
here the bishop on d4 is unguarded same
as gergan it says the rook was unguarded
went I'll start his attack here the
bishop is also on guard and it seems
like it's very hard to go after this
bishop but not really I
that Natsuki will show so he plays
Knight captures an f3 for those of you
who just wanted to enjoy the show if any
of you found this then really
congratulations it's a it's the start of
one of the greatest attacks well in 2019
definitely but also ever with G captures
on f3 if you don't capture it we're not
even gonna analyze that because well
black can just win material it's not
even it's not even tense if we don't
capture it so G captures on f3 and now
you continue with Knight captures on e4
and here all hell breaks loose so there
are so many possible options do you
capture on g7 do allow Bishop captures
on d4 with check do you capture the
night with the pawn do you move the
bishop do you capture the night with the
night so yeah we're just gonna cover the
well the very important option so
obviously well first thing that comes to
mind is I'm not gonna allow Bishop the
d4 check that's first thing we're gonna
check so let's see what happens there if
Bishop captures on g7 then you get a
Queen g5 check and now you see that the
bishop at night really make it awkward
for the King like we mentioned and the
night covers the f2 squares so the King
doesn't really have all that many
squares problem is if you walk Knight g3
then just Knight captures on g3 H
captures and now Queen captures and g3
width check if you go here then Bishop
captures on f3 just ends the game so you
can block Bishop g2 but now the Queen
attacks the rook
so rook captures with Czech rook
captures you get Queen captures with
check King moves and now you can just
recapture the bishop here you are up the
exchange White's defenses are completely
shattered you are completely winning
here so that's only one of the things
that can happen after a bishop captures
and g7 however after Queen g5 check why
doesn't have to block with the knight
white can also block with the bishop
then we make use of this diagonal really
really awesome stuff
Queen c5 check now you have to block
otherwise if King of one Queen 2 f2 is
mate
the knife covers the f2 squares so nice
the f2 has to be played you have to
clear the h1 square for your king it
doesn't really matter Queen captures
here king h1 and now again the Queen
attacks the rook on e1 just 93 check
this is just beautiful H captures rook
captures width check
we get pretty much the same stuff
captures captures with checking h2 and
now you either recapture right away or
or continue playing in great style with
h4 just a very very impressive G capture
screen captures with check in goes back
you can give another check pick up the
bishop now and again and now you also
open up the H file for your rook it's
completely over so although it seems
like you don't want to allow a bunch of
captures on d4 you really have to since
we've just shown that Bishop captures
here due to this nasty Queen g5 check it
simply doesn't work so another option is
well this is the strongest defense but
calculating this in an actual over the
board game very unlikely although it's
hard to say that it's the best defense
because it loses also by force Bishop to
e3 is is the seaming with the best
defense since you don't allow Bishop
captures but you also don't capture on
g7 point being Knight g5 by plaque by
black now piling up on the f3 pawn this
will come with to check the bishop also
attacks that you will have to remove it
Bishop captures Queen captures with
check now you're blocked Knight g3 but
now you have rook captures on e1 rook
captures anyone and now just Bishop
captures on f3 and well here you will
just know there's there's not much you
can do here yes you are now you are up a
piece but it will not do you any good
I mean you can easily win it back
whenever you want to
Queen to c5 check is coming and well
also once this bishop comes to d4 with
check it's game over with the light
square Bishop slicing through this
diagonal it's just well a lot like I
said the bishop pair from hell is fully
operational in every line we check so
after Knight captures on e4 let's check
Knight captures on e4
this doesn't work well now you capture
the bishop with check first of course
Knight H - f - you clear the h1 square
for your King rook captures and c1 rook
captures and c1 and now Bishop captures
on e4 the night here is pinned so F
captors on e4 and again you get Queen g5
check in and now this check connects
with the rook and c1 so in every line
you check the one of the rooks is
getting picked off by the Queen which is
just awesome and
doesn't really matter what you play you
can even block with the queen of queen
characters here you're up the exchange
of course and and in a completely
winning position so lastly now deublin
decided to capture with the point he
played f captures an e4 but now the a
similar variation appears Bishop
character son d4 with check 9 F two
blocks and now not Queen g5 but rather
Queen to h4 threatening Queen captures
here and also you keep the g5 squared
free for the row if needed you can do a
nice rook lift with rook to c5 followed
by rook to g5 check
we have rook to c2 defending the knight
here and now while rook the c5 is a
perfectly viable plan followed by rope
to g5 but Natalie goes further for the
most forcing variation removing the
defender of the pawn on e4 rook captures
on c3 we have B captures on c3 and now
of course Queen to g5 check this comes
first you have to prepare you have to
kick away the the King either to the
light square diagonal to face the light
square bishop or in the case of this
game Queen like I said if King to h1
then it's just a rook captures on e4 you
open up this diagonal and that's just
over whatever you play doesn't really
matter captures captures with the check
you're gonna go tonight capture Sonny
for or you block with the bishop then
it's just queen g2 mate or you capture
here and then you free the g1 square for
the Queen Quincy Quincy one is made here
so after Queen to g5 we have Bishop the
g2 blocking but now the same idea
applies rook captures on e4 opening up
this diagonal now if the rook moves with
check Queen captures here will be made
so you have to react to this we do have
to check rook captures on e4 first but
it's the same Bishop captures now made
this threatened you cannot capture due
to the pin you can start running away
King f1 but it also ends in in a forced
mate Queen captures ng to check King he
won Queen g1 check you're gonna move
king d2 the support Queen captures
doesn't really matter because the king
is unable to escape anywhere this is
just a very slow death
rooks t1 you clear something for the
King but not really Bishop e3 check and
here you just get made it check check
here and Bishop
f 3 again mate delivered by well your
your favorite bishop pair from hell so
after route captures any for trying to
capture or any other move doesn't really
do so King to f1 was played but now we
you know it's not I mean every great
game
Murphy's Opera House game is a brilliant
game but it wouldn't be a brilliant game
without the finish to that game so once
again feel free to pause the video and
try to find the best move in this
position while I give you a few seconds
so I'm sure a lot of you were able to do
it since I mentioned Murphy's Opera
House game but in case you didn't and
you just wanted to enjoy the show its
Queen captures and g2 with checks so
congratulations everyone who found that
white is without a move here white has
to go under the diagonal of the light
square bishop and here it's just over
King captures was played rook capture
sunny anyone with Czech opening up a
discovery from the light square bishop
and here if you start running away let's
say King G or King g3 it's a force made
Bishop e5 check King h4 Bishop f6 check
forcing the team back rook to e3 check
your gonna go King to f4 and now just
rook the f3 will be a delivered mate all
of the all of the squares are covered
here as you can see by the bishop to the
points and the row covers these these
two files so after Luke captures any one
Knight to e4 giving the King some some
more squares but it doesn't help just
disrupt Capra's on e4 with check King g3
and rook to g1 check and it was in this
position unmoved 28th remember this is
only moved 28 it seems like it's a
longer game because we've covered so
many lines but it's really not it's move
28 and here mark Narciso deublin
resigned which kind of you know it's a
you know a sour bite to end the meal so
to say if your opponent beats you it's
always hard to accept defeat but if your
opponent beats you like this then you
allow to see the mate on the board if
the game continued we would see King h4
now comes Bishop to f6 check King h3 and
Bishop f5 is now mate delivered again by
your favorite Bishop air from hell and
it doesn't help if you go to h3 instead
of an h4 it's just a different move
order Bishop f5 check English for and
now Bishop to f6 check again the bishop
air from hell is well and it gets the
job done so now that's the game I
decided to start the year with I do hope
you guys approve I mean now it's hard to
say if it's the best game of 2019 but I
do I do believe it is if you enjoy a
games like these I will also put two
games in the description below so you
can check them out also played in in
2019 one by one by the Indian towel and
the other one by by mulac Arthur King
and those are two really awesome game so
you can maybe compare this game to those
two games really awesome stuff if you
have the time so once again I do hope
you approve of my choice which game
starts our year on this channel also I
wanted to mention I said I do have an
announcement I will make a livestream I
will try to do it maybe maybe on Friday
or on Saturday mmm we will play some
chess but mostly about I'm starting a
podcast and I will give you some updates
about the chess manga I've been
mentioning from time to time and well it
can just also be a just a stream where
you can ask me stuff about that and I
will answer them
you know while we enjoy some chess
that's what I wanted to say I will
inform you when it will take place yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Philip bill allow
Deborah Mordecai around Crouch Slobodan
bercovich and Timothy Rosen for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing well to check up on
your wonderful suggestions preparing the
next big saga which is the Paul Morphy
saga and well that's pretty much it and
the the Tata still is starting a fairly
soon so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and hope you achieve everything you
you set for yourselves in the in the
upcoming year see you soon